It can’t be easy to keep secrets for a movie
as big — and exciting — as Avengers 4,
but these actors probably could have tried
a little harder.
These are a few of the biggest slip-ups by
the leading lights of the MCU.
A tiny detail
There’s been plenty of speculation that
the Quantum Realm will come into play in a
major way in Avengers 4 — and it looks like
Tom Holland may have confirmed that this is
the case.
Speaking with Benedict Cumberbatch in a video
released by Emergency Awesome, Holland referenced
the Quantum Realm specifically when comparing
his dialogue in Avengers 4 to Cumberbatch's.
“He has to talk about so much quantum realm stuff.. just stuff.
"I just have to say 'this is awesome.   this is cool!”
Unless the dialogue Holland is referring to
is along the lines of, "Gee, I'm relieved
we don't have to deal with any of that dumb
Quantum Realm stuff," then it's a safe bet
the strange place Scott Lang is trapped in
is going to hold some importance in the final
battle against Thanos.
Long live the Queen
While promoting Mission: Impossible – Fallout,
Angela Bassett — who played T'Challa's mother
Ramonda in Black Panther — revealed to ScreenRant
that Ramonda and Shuri survived Thanos' purge
at the end of Avengers: Infinity War.
When asked if her character was killed, Bassett
replied:
"No.
Neither did my daughter.
Shuri, she's a bright girl there in Wakanda."
The fact that both characters survived could
have a serious impact on the story of Avengers
4 and beyond.
On the one hand, with T'Challa dead, the survival
of Shuri and Ramonda may help determine who
takes the throne.
On the other, when last we saw Shuri, she
was trying to separate the Mind Stone from
Vision without killing him; she didn't succeed,
but she still might have gained valuable knowledge
which our heroes could use in the coming battle
against Thanos.
The women of Marvel
In an interview with Paper Magazine, Pom Klementieff
— who plays Mantis in the Guardians films
and Infinity War — was asked about the #MeToo
movement, and her response may have unintentionally
revealed a team-up between Mantis, Captain
Marvel and Okoye.
She recalled:
"I remember Brie Larson coming to me and Danai
Gurira [ on the set of
The Avengers.
She told me about the [Time's Up] letter to
sign and I found it really amazing to have
all these women — and men too — together
in fighting for a better world."
Mantis may have been one of the victims of
Thanos' purge at the end of Avengers: Infinity
War, but Klementieff's words would imply that
her death won't be entirely permanent.
And if we're getting a team-up between those
three, it begs the question of just where
it's happening.
Have Mantis and Captain Marvel made their
way to Earth, or is Okoye somehow traveling
the stars?
Reunited
Since Avengers 4 promises to be Robert Downey
Jr.'s final work in the MCU, fans wouldn't
be blamed for assuming Tony Stark might not
survive to see Pepper Potts again.
Tony was already a top choice for the Avengers:
Infinity War kill list and it's a good bet
the stakes will be raised even higher for
Avengers 4.
Thanks to Gwyneth Paltrow's Instagram page,
however, we know Tony and Pepper will get
to see each other at least one more time.
“I’m sorry."
In September 2018, while Avengers 4 was in
the middle of reshoots, Paltrow posted a photo
of her and Downey on set.
The caption read simply "lunchtime", accompanied
by "#pepperony," — a mash-up of Pepper and
Tony.
So we may not know whether Pepper or Tony
will survive Avengers 4, but we do know that
their scene in Infinity War wasn't the last
time the pair would see each other.
The good old days
The same day Gwyneth Paltrow posted her "#pepperony"
shot on Instagram, Chris Evans posted a selfie
on Twitter unveiling a relatively minor spoiler
to eagle-eyed fans — but one that could
point to a much larger reveal.
In the photo, Evans' Infinity War facial hair
is gone and his hair more closely resembles
the look we've seen in earlier films.
The shot's caption reads "Senior Year" and
is followed by "#A4."
As Thor correctly pointed out during Infinity
War's Battle of Wakanda, the star-spangled
Avenger assumed a much scruffier look in Infinity
War.
“New haircut?"
"Notice you've copied my beard!"
Now, this photo could simply mean that by
the end of Avengers 4 Steve Rogers will decide
he's not keen on beards anymore.
However, the idea that the Avengers will be
bouncing around time is one of the more heavily
trafficked theories about Avengers 4.
Evans could easily have been involved in reshoots
for a scene involving a Captain America from
another era.
In particular, the photo gives credence to
a fan theory that was already growing in popularity
— that Captain America will not die in Avengers
4, but will instead be sent back in time to
live the life with Peggy Carter that his long
sleep in the ice stole from him.
If true, it could be a beautiful end to the
character's story.